at the center of our societies is a
hugely inventive force dedicated to
nudging us towards a heightened
appreciation of certain aspects of the
world with enormous skill it throws into
relief that's very best sides of
particular places and objects it uses
wordsmiths an image makers of near
genius who can create deeply inspiring
and beguiling associations and position
works close to our eye lines at most
moments of the day advertising is the
most compelling agent of mass
appreciation that we have ever known
because advertising is so ubiquitous it
can be easy to forget that of course
only a very few sorts of things ever get
advertised almost nothing in the world
is in a position to afford the budgets
required by a campaign advertising is a
form of love overwhelmingly reserved for
those wealthy potentates of Modern Life
nappies cereal bars conditioners hand
sanitizers or family sedans this has a
habit of skewing our sense of priorities
one of our major flaws as animals and a
big contributor to our unhappiness is
that we're very bad at keeping in mind
the real ingredients of happiness we
lose sight of the value of almost
everything that's readily to hand
we're deeply ungrateful towards anything
that's free or doesn't cost very much we
trust in the value of objects more than
ideas or feelings with sluggish in
remembering to love and to care and
we're prone to racing through the years
forgetting the Wonder fragility and
beauty of existence it's fortunate
therefore that we have art one way to
conceive of what artists do is to think
that they are in their own way running
advertising campaigns not for anything
expensive or usually even available for
purchase but for the many things that
are at once of huge human importance and
yet constantly in danger of being
forgotten in the early part of the 21st
century the English artist David Hockney
ran a major advertising campaign for
trees
at the start of the 16th century the
German painter Albrecht Durer launched a
comparable campaign around the value of
grass and in the 1830s the Danish artist
Kristin koepka did a lot of advertising
for the sky especially just before or
after a rain shower in a psychological
field the French painter Pierre Bona
carried out an exceptionally successful
campaign for tenderness turning out
hundreds of images of his partner marked
viewed through lenses of sympathy
concern and understanding in an
associated move the American painter
Mary Cassatt made a pretty good case for
the world-beating importance of spending
some time with a child these were all
acts of Justice not condescension
they were much-needed correctives to the
way that what we call glamour is so
often located in unhelpful places in
what's rare remote costly or youthful if
advertising images carry a lot of the
blame for instilling sickness in our
souls the images of artists can
reconcile us with our reality and
reawaken us to the genuine but too
easily forgotten value of our own lives
consider Sharda as painting women taking
tea the sitter's dress might be a bit
more elaborate than is normal today but
the painted table teapot chair spoon and
cup could all be picked up at a flea
market
the room is studiously plain and yet the
picture is glamorous it makes this
ordinary occasion and the simple
furnishings seductive it invites the
beholder to go home and create their own
live version the glamour is not a false
sheen that pretends something lovely is
going on when it isn't shudder
recognizes the worth of a modest moment
and marshals his genius to bring its
qualities to our notice it lies in the
power of art to honor the elusive but
real value of ordinary life it may teach
us to be more just towards ourselves as
we endeavor to make the best of our
humble circumstances a job we don't
always love the imperfections of age are
frustrated ambitions and our attempts to
stay loyal to some
irritable families art can do the
opposite of glamorize the unattainable
it can reawaken us to the genuine merit
of life as we're forced to lead it it's
advertising for the things we really
need
thank you for watching liking and
subscribing if you want more why not
visit us in person and attend a class or
take a look at our shop at the link on
your screen now
you